a new dawn for British trade with
Australia that's what both countries
hope as they launch free trade talks
today we regard this is a very important
priority the United Kingdom is
Australia's seventh largest trading
partner it used to be by the way before
Britain joined the Common Market our
most important trading partner
strengthening old friendships also vital
in an era of change led by the rise of
China the closeness of the relationship
between Britain and Australia has never
been more important than it is now at a
time when there are tensions in the
world that are growing more acute and
which have been dramatized and thrown
into very stark relief by the covert
crisis the the benefit the importance to
each other of like-minded free trading
liberal democracies like Britain and
Australia has never been greater we're
trying to forge these new free trade
agreements but it's piecemeal compared
to the volume of trade we did with the
EU were facing a potential no deal at
the end of this year what do you say to
those critics I don't call it on what
may happen between the United Kingdom
and the EU after the 31st of December
but I simply make this point the voices
of pessimism in discussions about global
trade are always in the end watered by
the reality because because merchants
traders entrepreneurs companies always
gravitate to the most profitable markets
the most rapidly growing markets in the
world at the moment and as far as the
eye can see in the region to the north
of Australia Canberra will be eyeing
opportunity in Britain as well for
sectors like agriculture and banking
both sides know there'll be bumps along
the way but hope to strike a deal in
months not years Australia's prime
minister Scott Morrison should have
travelled to the UK this week to launch
the talks in person with Boris Johnson
a party was even planned here at the
High Commission coronavirus stopped all
that but this global health emergency
has also underlined the importance for
allies like the UK and Australia to work
even more closely together the US Japan
and New Zealand UK priorities as well
for trade talks as we seek to recover
from Korean virus it's really important
we reach out and link up with the rest
of the world but Australia New Zealand
are also part of the trans-pacific
partnership which is worth 110 billion
pounds worth of trade so doing a deal
with Australia New Zealand also opens up
those other markets T so there are real
opportunities for British business from
cars to whiskey to steel to open up
those new markets and help them export
as they seek to grow their businesses
new horizons even as the UK struggles to
seal a deal with its closest market the
EU Deborah Haim Sky News